- [Instructor] So I have
a two by two matrix here
and we could view it as
having two column vectors.
So the first column can
define this vector three, one,
which I've depicted in blue here.
And then that second
column, you can view it
as telling us that we have
another vector, one, two,
which I have depicted in this pink color.
Now, an interesting
interpretation of the determinant
of this two by two matrix is that
the absolute value of the determinant
is the area of the parallelogram defined
by these two vectors.
What I mean by the parallelogram defined
by these two vectors?
Well, imagine taking this
bottom vector and shifting it
so it's tail is at the
head of this pink vector.
So it would look like this, hand draw it.
Looks something like that.
And then if you were to
take this pink vector
and copy it and shift
it up into the right.
So its tail is at the head
of the original blue vector.
It's going to look something like that.
And so you can see, you
can use that technique
to take any two vectors
in the coordinate plane.
And they will define a parallelogram.
And it turns out that the area
of this parallelogram is going to be equal
to the absolute value of the determinant
of this matrix here.
So what's that going to be?
Well, we know of figure
out the determinant.
It is three times two, which is six.
Minus one times one, which is
one, which is equal to five.
And of course the absolute
value of five is five.
Now that's pretty cool in and of itself.
We figured out one
interpretation of a determinant
which will be useful as we build up
our understanding of matrices.
But another interpretation
is to say, all right,
what if A is a transformation matrix,
and I'm just rewriting it.
So we know what a
transformation matrix does.
It tells us what to do with
the unit vectors, so to speak.
So for example, I have
this vector right over here
which is the vector one, zero.
We know that a transformation
matrix says, all right
take that one, zero vector
and turn it into the three, one vector.
So turn that into that right over there.
And we know we have the
other, or another unit vector.
Let's call this, this right over here
is the zero, one vector.
Goes zero in the X direction,
one in the Y direction.
And the transformation matrix says,
hey, turn that into the one, two vector.
But then you can think about it,
it's also not just transforming
the individual vectors.
It's also scaling up the
area defined by the vectors.
So the area defined by these two original,
we could say unit vectors,
we can see it's one by one.
It's that area right over there.
So this transformation is taking us
from an area of one to an area, five.
It's scaling it up by a factor of five.
Now that's reasonably interesting
just for this one unit square.
But because of that
it'll actually scale up
the area of any figure.
Let's say had a figure like this.
So this type of oval circle
thing, it has some area.
If you apply this transformation matrix
it will look something like this.
I'm just approximating it.
It would look something like that.
So this will tell us that this bigger blob
has five times the area
of this original blue blob
because the bigger blob is the image.
Once we've transformed the smaller blob
by this transformation matrix.
So if I were to tell you
that the area of this smaller
circle is let's say 0.6
but then we were to
apply the transformation.
And someone were to ask you,
what is the area of this bigger blob?
Which is the image of the smaller circle
after the transformation?
Well, you take 0.6, multiply
it by the absolute value
of the determinant of the
transformation matrix.
You'd multiply it by five.
So 0.6 times five would
be three square units.
And a hint at the reason
why this works is,
is that any region on the coordinate plane
can be represented as a series of squares.
And then if you apply the transformation
you're really just transforming each
of those individual squares.
So the scaling up of the area
would be the same scale you do
to any one of those smaller squares.